it looks like the next major Assassin's
Creed game is coming and you'd better
brush up on your English accent because
Assassin's Creed Victory is heading to
London set in the 19th century
specifically within the Victorian era
the game is allegedly well on its way
for a release date next fall according
to a report from kitaku their Source
suggested that development for the game
will be headed up by ubisoft's office in
Quebec and not Ubisoft Montreal who have
traditionally taken the lead on
Assassin's games Victory is supposedly
coming to Xbox One PS4 and PC and will
be the only major AC game to land in the
full release period that should serve as
a small concession for those of you who
are feeling a little inundated with the
Creed this year kitaku reported that
they have also seen a 7-minute gameplay
footage video that featured City
traversal Combat on top of moving
carriages as well as the introduction of
a grappling hook the report indicated
that the game was running on ubisoft's
Anvil engine which powered Assassin's
Creed Unity let me know if you're Keen
for another Assassin's game or not and
what you think about the Victorian
setting as always stay tuned to gam SWAT
for more
updates